we're back we're back guys I I mean I
said this but I wept through the entire
movie for various reasons oh my gosh the
emotional punches the animation Gwen's
World being like a mood ring and like oh
I just loved it did you see it on a
plane because at altitude I watched it
on my phone away as it was on an Apple
Watch the original 65 millimeter because
that's what Lord Miller would have
wanted great how many spider people are
in this movie do you know the number
um it is somewhere between 150 and 240.
I'm trying to get a Full Count there's a
bit of a dispute
um but there were many many many
characters designed from head to toe
complete with like each having their own
unique unique comic book style it was a
a major effort what was something that
you didn't get to do in the first movie
that you got to do this time around that
was the most exciting nobody has asked
us that yet I mean are you being
sarcastic no I swear to Heaven I mean
the fact that we could go deeper into
these characters was really good I mean
we got to see Gwen in the first movie as
just a really cool confident
aspirational uh person right we got her
backstory for five seconds right in the
last one and now we get like a whole
reel to really understand where it's
coming from you know her as a whole full
person and people just dig deeper into
these characters was really cool but
also the fact that we could actually go
into the spider-verse even though the
first film was called into the
spider-verse this time we get to go to
all these different worlds and see all
these different styles of animation and
all these looks that you've never seen
before and give the audience uh a new
experience how do you always
I had the trilogy in mind
yeah
we knew we wanted there's more to tell
and there's a lot to explore but it
wasn't until we were working on this
film that we realized that this this
thing that became across the
spider-verse was the middle piece of a
Trilogy and now we actually have a
proper plan and know what we're doing
but you know at the time we were sort of
just painting ourselves into a corner
and trying to find a way out there's a
lot of characters in the first one that
we're they're kind of off doing their
own thing in this one Aunt May in the
first one says can you hook me up with
someone can you set me up on a dating
app do you think she met someone oh and
that's why she moved down that's why she
moved to Florida of course that's a
pretty good yeah yeah she met someone
online and you know she's an impulsive
person so I wonder if she just like went
down there I'm kind of worried about her
yeah we don't know because they've never
met in person she just went down there
and do you think she could be getting
catfish
no you know she's very vulnerable yes no
she's not you're right she's she can
take care of herself so is is beyond the
ending or do you have it is it is the
end of the Miles Morales Trilogy and so
this whole thing is like working towards
that but this obviously has its own
complete film with a beginning middle
and end and Miles starts in one place
and ends in another and
um and all the characters have an arc in
this film in it and but
that's it for for us we're so tired is
it because what was up the the
Spider-Man Noir oh yes we
yes we are happening happening we are so
producing a a silk show about Cindy Moon
and uh Spider-Man Noir shows are live
action television shows
um they're on hold right now with a
writer strike uh but
um hopefully once it's over we'll get
back up and going does that mean
Nicholas Cage
anything is possible in the Multiverse
um one of my favorite fun facts about
the first one is that the frame rate of
Miles kind of changes and evolves as the
movie goes on yeah was there anything
that uh in this one that you felt like
you're most proud of that maybe viewers
won't catch on the first go around uh
speaking of frame rates I think um Hobie
Brown is uh is on like fours and fives
some of the time because he's like made
out of zines and and uh we're really
proud of how that character wound up
looking
um because we really wanted to feel like
it was made out of like cut paper was he
the hardest to get right or was that
actually yes it's hard to make like it's
really hard to make a computer make
something look crummy like a xerox
machine ran out of toner right and and
uh and it's also like also for our
artists who's like whole job is to make
everything look really fancy and
expensive it's like can you make it look
like you did it in your basement like
really fast out of pieces of garbage
um and the spot in his final form was
one of the hardest things to get to look
right and have it feel like ink on paper
mixed with an oil on glass make sure
there's a bunch of other art techniques
it feels
um you know like a surreal experience uh
and like nothing you've ever seen that
was so cool to me because at the
beginning I was like okay is this goofy
gonna go away and then by the end it
felt like bad trip Vibes like I was
terrified that's that's the goal it's a
sucker punch right it's the origin it's
like a coming-of-age story for the
villain yeah right and just like it is
for Miles just like it is for like all
the parents in the movie like
everybody's growing up